da bastelten die aufnahme und es ist der
crafter
willkommen zu einer ganz klassischen
runde pvp werden heute ein zwei drei
vier fünf runden zurück und spielen mit
krane leider recht weil es einfach
momentan so richtig viel rock mafia 2 hd
der server richtiges projekt also es
echt heftig ihr werdet schon sehen dann
doch mal eingestehen muss dass er die
aufnahme und ist der wurde von r wurde
fast von konflikt leute dass ich auf
jeden fall ein titel wie er dank max ok
und ja wie gesagt so eben gerade nicht
so viele bestellungen müssen die ganzen
menschen angelegt leute was wird aus
diesem server mein gott
ja klar das ist so es so heftig
aufgekommene benzin instrumenten möchte
einfach sagen aber nicht gut aber es hat
mich erwischt geborgen mich zu retten
da hätten wir wo bist du
weise hatte er sieht relativ gut aus
läuft aber auf den hof steps also da
müssen wir im red bull ist im ghetto was
ein ghetto oder der love teilte der rock
was ist lag an dem ast aus unserem
server direkt mit zu sehr
warte die ketten und mit kann kurz denn
dann abstand bist du mich verarschen
hast du grad verbrannt
kann jemand so vital sein wie du weiter
du bist doch echt die größten missgeburt
diesen planeten wachs alter das
heftigste ich habe es einfach gar keine
waffe zugeworfen er genau dem moment
passiert der fns und verbrennt die
einfach und dann bin ich schuld weil ich
die waffe geworfen haben
das war nicht meine schuld
aber es war beim 7 stets wieder aus
einem großen
hier hinten sieht aus als hätte jemand
gefeit ist ich bin übrigens nicht bei
dir weil du gemeint hast wir sollen uns
trennen ich glaube auch dessen gegner
wahrscheinlich findet lagen praktisch im
kampf drei stufen laufen
ich frage mich auch was diese menschen
sich erwarten was denkst dort passiert
nach großen dieser runde wenn du von mir
weg läuft ganz ehrlich hier hoffnung
verstehe das nicht
ich meine wenn er so lobt darauf was
reißen würde
jetzt wieder so auch ghosn
also wenn ich sage dann meine ich den
server und ich den youtube
natürlich nichts oder doch keine ahnung
auf jeden fall im ernst wait and fresh
up lady hatte hat er sich pressure plays
gemacht aus eisen
egal ob de wever leise machen als in
dieser runde passieren richtig geile
sachen warum machen leute sind depressiv
nicht ausreisen wo sollte er uns ja komm
ich habe noch nie gesehen
man kann nicht loslassen
okay das stimmt das schon natürlich ist
da oben eine robert einen bogen nein sie
haben keine nachteile und java lag am
boden
rechts papier sagt barth gemeinsam mit
bad vilbel bad vilbel
vielleicht kann ja sein kann so dass
jetzt hier
nicht geschlagen
mit dem niemals wenn ich das ist lang
und es guckt euch das an es ist
unmöglich
wie soll man da spielen und warum legt
dennoch auf jeden fall keine ahnung was
da los weise installiert schauen warum
nächstes so viele leute sagen kann ich
bin tempel zu wissen wird
gut gebrauchen
ach leute das ist echt heftig was geht
mir grad ab und achten nutzer eine info
an der internetleitung kann es nämlich
nicht legen weil gewisse als ihr bewusst
aber ich sage nochmal max hat eine
200.000 der leitungen 50.000 upstream
also da kann es garantiert nicht daran
legen kommt leben wir denn noch haben
wir keine vertröstung mich verarschen
wollte what the [ __ ] hat der andere dir
überhaupt getroffen
guck mal wie viel sie mir doch gegeben
hat der nächste da oben schnell die
sachen schnell die sachen schnell die
sachen auf einen pakt abziehen
am besten lohn abziehen leider nichts
gutes zu essen was bitte ist am arsch
ich bin gerade mit zweieinhalb herzen
eschborn wo bist du alter ich bin fast
abgekratzt
der schluck wenn ich jetzt gerade komm
grad hoch ein bisschen zu viel leben ein
bisschen erstmal ein bisschen regen
leute vor wenn sie die große action
bis
fest was hast du für rüstung
ok service okay okay leute keine ahnung
was aber selten
naja kanal also wie gesagt ich weiß
nicht da kann man nichts machen aber ich
würde sagen was ganz wichtig ist wenn er
wieder handicap games haben wollt dann
schreibt eure challenges in die
kommentare
das letzte bisschen knapp ausgefallen
referee aber sagen ich hoffe die runde
hatte ich jetzt gefallen
das war einfach ein bisschen klassisch
survival games wir falls sie mehr da
fragen wollte natürlich gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
so wie immer gern gesehen wenn ihr tag
muss sie haben wollte und natürlich
sagen denn letzten winter beschreibung
den könnt euch gerne anschauen und dann
sieht man zunächst ein video bietet mit
entscheiden dass die heads in die
kommentare schreiben